there are two things that the
administration is trying to hide from
the american public
one is the massive number of people
who are coming across the border and the
bond administration's
lack of preparation to deal with this
massive number
the second thing they want to hide is
this and that is that with every person
coming across the border
it empowers and it enriches the drug
cartels
that from last hour texas governor greg
abbott very interesting conversation
addressing the crisis here it's not just
an issue in texas you're looking at an
exclusive
bird's eye view now of a new mexico
cattle ranchers property where the
unfinished border wall
leaves a nearly mile long gaping hole
after president biden hauled a
construction on the 20th of january
allowing migrants to easily cross
the border from mexico into the u.s
russell johnson
is that rancher and he's with us now and
sir thank you for your time
i've heard some comments from some
ranchers the general theme seems to be
they're afraid are you
well you know living down here on the
border you can't live in fear
but the way everything's going nowadays
with the
new policies put forth by this
administration it's making things a lot
more difficult and a lot more unsafe in
our area
what is do you have much law enforcement
uh there
in your area i mean it's pretty rural
part of the country
we're very rural um our sheriff's
department
is stretched pretty thin so when it
comes to law enforcement
we rely heavily on our border patrol
and their resources are stretched pretty
thin right now with the influx of
of illegal activity crossing especially
in like the santa teresa area which is
east of us
so that's that's allowing these criminal
elements in mexico to exploit this
and so foot traffic in our area has
increased significantly
since they halted border wall
construction what was the effect of that
when they stopped building the wall
there for you specifically because that
was
that was on your property right
correct we have a three-quarter mile gap
and along with another smaller gap
and and they're exploiting this we don't
have the unaccompanied minors coming
through our area what we have
is a criminal element a neighbor to our
west
had border patrol apprehend a group of
12 people they were wearing
camouflage and ski masks those aren't
upstanding people coming over here
looking for a job this
this is a criminal element that we are
dealing with out in these rural areas
russell johnson we're seeing a drone
footage of your ranch which is
absolutely stunning and a beautiful
place and no doubt you have so much
love for your land um i'm sure you have
a lot of livestock there
and you worry for them have you seen
evidence of any
sort of cartel activity or coyote
activity on the area
especially with drugs
i've never seen drug activity
specifically but like i say foot traffic
has increased significantly
approximately one mile from my house
last saturday the border patrol
picked up uh tracks the sign for a group
of 50 plus that went through that gate
and of that 50 they only caught 30 of
them so
the 20 20 other people made it through
and we have no idea who that was
or what they were doing or what they
were carrying it's the 19th of march i
apologize about the interruption there
it's the 19th of march what happens on
the 19th of april and the 19th of may do
you think with us
well that's one of our big concerns as
as the weather improves here and gets
warmer
it's going to make crossing a lot more
easier for these people
because the elements aren't going to be
as bad so
it's it's going to increase we're a
funneling point we're the
we're the first major gap coming west
out of el paso texas which is
approximately 90 miles away so
we're going to have a significant
increase of traffic to our area and it's
going to affect
the safety of of my family our business
the people of this county people don't
realize this isn't just a border problem
this affects
everybody we're just the first ones that
see it russell could i ask you
if you hear anything at all from your
elected leadership in washington d.c so
uh senators
uh congress people or even the new
secretary of interior
uh we've been in contact with uh
representative yvette herrell
and her office has been real good about
listening to our concerns and trying to
help us out with this matter but
other than that uh it's it's been silent
even our
our governor doesn't take notice of this
issue
and that's what's concerning to me is i
have a red state to my west and a red
state to the east
that if the federal government doesn't
take care of this issue
their state government will and that's
going to push all of their traffic to
new mexico good luck to you russell
thanks for sharing your story
russell johnson